[موسيقى]
مساء الخير لابو الطيب المتنبي بيت شعر
عبقري بيقول فيه الطويل طريقنا ام يطولوا
يعني الطريق ما بيخلصش وحرب روسيا
واوكرانيا او حرب روسيا مع الغرب على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه ما بتخلصش من يتابع
نشرات الاخبار هذه الايام يجب تطورا
ملحوظا اذ اصبح البحر الاسود والمسرح
الرئيسي الجديد لعمليات العسكريه هذه
الايام ما يطرح عده اسئله خلاصتها ماذا
يجري في البحر الاسود وكيف يمكن ان يؤثر
ذلك على باقي دول العالم محاوله الاجابه
على هذين السؤالين تقتني ان نعرف اولا اين
هو البحر الاسود النظر الى الخريطه يقدم
اسهل واسرع اجابه فهذا البحر الواقع ما
بين شرق اوروبا وغرب اسيا يربط عمليا اسيا
باوروبا وتطل عليه ست دول هي تركيا
وبلغاريا ورومانيا واوكرانيا وجورجيا
وطبعا روسيا ولهذا البحر اهميه كبيره لكل
اطراف الصراع فالتواجد فيه ان لم يكن
السيطره عليه هي مساله الحياه او موت
بالنسبه لروسيا روسيا بلد شبه حديث عمليا
طبعا هو ليس حبيسا بالمعنى الجغرافي لما
بنقول ان بلد شبه حديث ان بلد حبيسه
معناها انها محرومه من اي منفذ على
السواحل سواء سواحل البحار او محيطات كما
هو الحال بالنسبه لبلد مثل اثيوبيا او بلد
مثل النيجر
لكن روسيا هي بلد شبه حبيس بمعنى انه
محروم من سواحل طويله على المياه الدفيئه
وما هي المياه الدفيئه هي المياه التي
تصلح للملاحه طوال شهور السنه مثل البحر
الاحمر والبحر المتوسط والبحر الاسود
روسيا اكبر بلد في العالم لديه سواحل
طويله طبعا ولكن هذه السواحل اما انها
تتجمد في شهور الشتاء كما هو الحال في
حدودها او سواحلها الشماليه
بحر الشمال او انها واقعه تحت سيطره دول
غير صديقه كما هو الحال بالنسبه
لسواحلها على البحر على بحر اليابان شرقا
على هذا الساحل بيقع ميناء
الاستراتيجي الروسي المهم لكن كل السفن
اللي بتخرج من هذا الميناء مضطره لعبور
مضيق سوشيما اللي بتسيطر عليه اليابان من
ناحيه وكوريا الجنوبيه من ناحيه اخرى
وكوريا الجنوبيه واليابان حليفاني لحلف
شمال الاطلسي ما يعني انهما مستعدان
لاغلاق هذا المضيق امام عبور السفن
الروسيه في حال اندلاع اي عدائيات ماذا
يتبقى امام الروس يتبقى لهم البحر الاسود
وملحوظه طبعا لم يكن لروسيا تاريخيا منفذا
على هذا البحر هي حصلت على هذا المنفذ
بالقوه العسكريه بعد صراع طويل مع
الامبراطوريه العثمانيه
وهذه قصه يطول شرحها لكن الخلاصه ان البحر
الاسود هو بحر بالغ الاهميه للروس على كل
المستويات على المستوى التجاري هو شريان
حياه للروس بتستقبل من خلاله كثير من
وارداتها من دول العالم وبتصدر من خلال
موانئها في البحر الاسود الكثير من سلعها
وحبوبها الى باقي دول العالم استراتيجيا
بتتضاعف اهميه البحر الاسود لكونهم ممر
روسيا الوحيد للوصول الى البحر المتوسط
ومنه الى باقي دول العالم اذ يربط مضيق
البسفور البحر الاسود ببحر مرمره بينما
يربط مضيق الدردنيل بحر مرمره ببحر ايجا
وطبعا ايجه هو جزء من البحر المتوسط
ومن المتوسط تستطيع السفن الروسيه الابحار
حول العالم وبالتالي فالبحر الاسود ده هو
نقطه انطلاق يمكن لروسيا من خلالها
ممارسه النفوذ والوصول الى البحر الابيض
المتوسط والشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
لروسيا مثل سوريا اللي بتستضيف قاعدتين
عسكريتين لروسيا على المستوى العسكري
البحر الاسود بتقع عليه شبه جزيره القرم
وشبه جزيره القرم بتضم ميناء سيفستا بول
اللي بيستضيف او اللي بتستضيف اسطول البحر
الاسود الروسي منذ عام 1793 وكان حرص
روسيا على هذا الميناء رئيسي في قرارها ضم
شبه جزيره القرم في 2014
روسيا اللي بتفتخر لسواحل طويله على
المياه الدفيئه زي ما قلت لحضراتكم لا
تمتلك بدائل تذكر لهذا الميناء اللي
بيتمتع بمياه عميقه تمكنه من استقبال سفن
العسكريه ضخمه لكل هذه الاسباب خاضت روسيا
تاريخيا حروب كثيره معظمها ضد
الامبراطوريه العثمانيه لتامين مصالحها في
البحر الاسود لكن المساله مش بس تاريخيا
ده احنا في السنوات الاخيره شاهدنا اكثر
من حرب ايضا لتامين مصالح روسيا في البحر
الاسود
2008 غزت روسيا جورجيا وكان احد اسباب
الحرب هو دعم انفصال اقليم ابخزيه طب وهي
عاوزه ليه تدعم اقليم ابخزيها
والنتيجه انه روسيا بتسيطر الان على ما
يقرب من ثلث سواحل البحر الاسود على الرغم
من امتلاكها لحوالي 10% فقط من هذه
السواحل وفقا لحدودها القانونيه لانه معظم
دول العالم لا تعترف بضم روسيا لشبه جزيره
القرم ومعظم دول العالم لا تعترف بجمهوريه
افخاذيا ودي قصه يطول شرحها البحر الاسود
ليس اقل اهميه بالنسبه للاوكران لانه
شريان حياه لهم وعلى سبيل المثال بيمر
اكثر في المئه اكثر من 50% من اجمالي
صادرات اوكرانيا عبر البحر الاسود من خلال
ميناء اوديسا اللي هو اكبر موانئ اوكرانيا
بدون هذه الموانئ بدون البحر الاسود تصبح
اوكرانيا بلد حديث
البحر الاسود له اهميه كبيره للاتحاد
الاوروبي وحلف شمال الاطلسي فبالنسبه
للاتحاد الاوروبي هذا البحر هو ممر تجاري
رئيسي بين اسيا وبين الاتحاد الاوروبي
قاره اوروبا حلف الناتو له مصالح امنيه
قويه في المنطقه اولا لانه منطقه مواجهه
مع الاتحاد السوفيتي سابقا ومنطقه مواجهه
مع روسيا الاتحاديه حاليا وعلى البحر
الاسود ثلاثه من اعضاء الناتو لها حدود
مباشره على البحر هي بلغاريا ورومانيا
وتركيا طبعا صاحبه اهم نفوذ على هذا البحر
باعتبار ان هي
لبوتايق اللي منها بتمر روسيا الى باقي
دول العالم وبالمناسبه للحلف بيجرى
مناورات ثانويه في هذا البحر من عام
1997 كل هذا ليس جديدا انا اذكر حضراتكم
فقط بحقائق التاريخ والجغرافيا الجديد ان
الحرب تتركز الان في البحر الاسود ما يزيد
من اهميته وخطورته والسؤال الذي طرحناه في
اول الحلقه لماذا تتركز الحرب الان في هذا
البحر لعده اسباب اولها الحصار الغربي على
روسيا فمع بدايه الحرب فرض الغرب وعقوبات
خانقه على الروس
هذه العقوبات الاقتصاديه على الغرب زادت
شهرا بعد شهر ومع هذا الحصار الاقتصادي
زاد اعتماد الروس على الدول المطله على
الجانب الشرقي للبحر الاسود دول زي مين زي
تركيا وجورجيا وارمانيا هذه الدول اصبحت
منافذ غير مباشره لتجاره روسيا مع العالم
وهي قنوات
للالتفاف على العقوبات الغربيه على الروس
اصبح هناك بيزنس منتعش يقوم على فكره ان
تستورد شركات في هذه الدول ما تحتاجه
روسيا من الغرب ثم تعيد تصديره للروس
واعطيكم مثالا واحدا اختصارا للوقت وهو
جورجيا ارتفعت الصادرات الجورجيه الى
روسيا بنسبه 75 في المئه من النصف الاول
في النصف الاول من عام 2023
ليه لانه جورجيا بتستورد ما يحتاجه الروس
ثم بتعيد تصديره الى روسيا مباشره او عبر
اقليم ومن اقليم ابخازيا الى الداخل
الروسي دول اوروبيه لاحظت انتعاشا كبيرا
جدا في صادراتها الى دول بعينها مثل
جورجيا وارمينيا او حتى دول اسيا الوسطى
اللي برضو بتساعد الروس على الالتفاف على
العقوبات الغربيه ببساطه لانها بتستفيد
يعني مش بالضروره حبا في روسيا وعلى سبيل
المثال في الربع الاول من العام الجاري
2023 ارتفعت الصادرات الالمانيه الى
جورجيا بنسبه 48% والى ارمينيا بنسبه 132
في المئه وطبعا هذه الزيادات لا تعبر عن
تضخم في اقتصادات هذه الدول او نموا
مضطردا ولكن هي فقط دول بتستورد ما تحتاجه
روسيا ثم تعيد تصديره الى الروس ويستفيدون
اعتماد روسيا على هذه الدول المتشاطئه او
اللي بتقع في منطقه البحر الاسود بيزيد من
اهميه البحر الاسود لروسيا السبب الثاني
هو بدء الهجوم المضاد لاوكرانيا اللي رفعت
سقف طموحاتها وبدات تستهدف الوجود الروسي
في شبه جزيره القرد الواقعه على البحر
الاسود
وبتسعى لقطع الجسر البري اللي بيربط روسيا
بشبه جزيره القرد الواقعه على البحر
الاسود
ثالثا بعد انسحاب روسيا من اتفاق الحبوب
سعه فيوليو الماضي اللي هو يعني 2023 من
اسابيع قليله ساعه روسيا لشل كل قدرات
اوكرانيا على تصدير الحبوب لهدفين الهدف
الاول حرمان الاوكران من عوائد تقدر بنحو
مليار دولار من صادراتها
لحبوب الحيويه اللي بيتم تصديرها عبر
ميناء اوليسا الواقع على البحر الاسود
والسبب الثاني حرمان حلف اء اوكرانيا من
هذه الحبوب لان معظم هذه الحبوب بتذهب الى
حلفاء اوكرانيا في الغرب
في المقابل اراد الغرب وارادت اوكرانيا
الرد على هذه الخطوه الروسيه فبداوا
يستهدفوا الموانئ الروسيه والسفن الروسيه
في البحر الاسود كوسيله ضغط لاجبار روسيا
الاول للعوده للاتفاق اللي هو اتفاق
الحبوب ووقف الهجمات على الموانئ
الاوكرانيه وطبعا محاوله تقويه جهود روسيا
في السيطره على البحر الاسود اساسا وبدات
اوكرانيا فعلا باستهداف السفن الروسيه في
البحر الاسود كما حدث بنجاح في يومي اربعه
وخمسه اغسطس الماضي واصدرت تحذيرا لكل دول
العالم خلاصته ان موانئ روسيا الاساسيه
الست على البحر الاسود والطرق المؤديه لها
باتت مناطق خطره لكونها تحت مرمى نيران
اوكرانيا
وطبعا هذا التحذير مفتوح حتى اشعار اخر
ببساطه الاخرى الروس بيحاولوا شل الاقتصاد
الاوكراني اللي راته الاساسيه على البحر
الاسود والاوكران والغرب بيحاول شل
الاقتصاد الروسي اللي رات الاساسيه على
البحر الاسود
افتح كوسين كبار واحب ان اذكر حضراتكم
لماذا دخلت روسيا اتفاق الحبوب ولماذا
انسحبت منه اتفاق الحبوب ابرم بين روسيا
مع باقي دول العالم بوساطه الامم المتحده
وتركيا في يوليو 2022 وكان الهدف منه الا
يتعرض العالم لازمه غذاء نتيجه الحرب
الدائره بين روسيا واوكرانيا وكلاهما من
اكبر منتجه الغذاء في العالم وفقد روسيا
وكانت الموافقه تقتضي ان تخفف حصارها على
الموانئ الاوكرانيه على البحر الاسود
ولكنها بدات تتحفظ على هذا الاتفاق بمجرد
تنفيذه وكان وجهه نظرها انه الاتفاق على
مدار الشهور هي كانت بتشتكي انه هذا
الاتفاق يصب فقط في صالح الاوكران
وحلفائها لماذا ايها الروس بتقول لانه هذا
الاتفاق نظريا بيقول لي انا من حقيقي اصدر
حبوبي ومن حق اوكرانيا تصدر حبوبها علشان
اوكرانيا تصدر حبوبها انا رفعت الحصار عن
اوكرانيا فبدا تتدفق حبوبها الى العالم
الخارجي لكن انا حبوبي لا تتدفق الى
العالم الخارجي فالغرب قولي لها يقول لها
والله حبوبك ليست خاضعه لاي عقوبات غربيه
صدري كما تشائي فتقول لهم روسي طب انا
اصدر ازاي اذا كنتم انتم فارضين عقوبات
بتشل قدرتي على الانتاج وعلى التجاره في
حبوبي
واشترطت انه لكي تستمر في هذا الاتفاق
لابد من مجموعه شروط الشرط الاول ربط
البنك الزراعي الروسي المملوك لروسيا
والخادع للعقوبات
للمدفوعات علشان البنك يقدر يصدر ويقدر
يتعامل مع العالم الخارجي محتاج ان يكون
مربوطا بالنظام المالي العالمي وهو مقطوع
عنه اتنين رفع القيود المفروده على شركات
التامين اللي ممنوعه من التعامل مع
الشركات والسفن الروسيه وبالتالي بتحد من
قدره السفن الروسيه للوصول الى كل دول
العالم ثلاثه انهاء العقوبات الغربيه
المفروضه على شركات الاسمده الضروريه جدا
للعمليه الزراعيه ما انت لازم تنتج اسمده
علشان تنتج محاصيل زراعيه اربعه استعاده
خط انابيب الامونيا الذي يعبر اوكرانيا من
روسيا الى اوروبا دي شروط الاساسيه الروس
قالوا للغرب علشان اقدر اصدر حبوبي
وبالتالي يستمر اتفاق الحبوب رد الغرب
والله انتوا كده بلغتم جدا في مفهوم
الاتفاق انتم باختصار كده عاوزين تتحايلوا
او تحيدوا كل العقوبات المفروضه عليكم
وهذا المفروض رد الغرب رده روسيا بالخروج
من الاتفاق نهائيا في يوليو 2023 يعني من
عده اسابيع وقررت ان هي تشل قدره اوكرانيا
على تصدير اي حبوب
عن طريق البحر الاسود
وتشل الاقتصاد الاوكراني بكليته وبدات
اعاده احكام الحصار على الموانئ
الاوكرانيه وضرب هذه الموانئ وكل الطرق
المؤديه اليها وبدا الاوكران يردون كما
قلت لحضراتكم باستهداف الموانئ والسفن
الروسيه الموجوده في البحر الاسود اضف الى
ذلك ان الاتحاد الاوروبي بعد الحرب اراد
ان يتوقف عن استيراد البترول والغاز
الروسي
وعليه بدا يبحث عن بدائل واحد من هذه
البدائل هو التوسع في استيراد البترول
والغاز من منطقتي القوقاز وبحر قزوين
وتحديدا كازاخستان واضرب عجان ومن
المنطقتين الى البحر الاسود بعيدا عن
روسيا في الشمال وعن ايران في الجنوب
الدولتين اللي هما يعني في خصوبه مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي
الحاصل الان ان روسيا واوكرانيا
حرب تشبه حرب الناقلات اللي شنتها العراق
وايران في الثمانينيات في الخليج العربي
كل دوله بتسعى لشل اقتصاد الدوله الاخرى
بضرب سفلها وموانئها في البحر الاسود
هذه المساعي طبعا تؤثر على الدولتين ولكن
بعيدا عن الدولتين سوف تعمق هذه الحرب
ثلاثه ثلاثه مخاطر عالميه الخطر الاول هو
تعميق ازمه الغذاء قبل بدء الحرب كانت
روسيا واوكرانيا بيصدرانى معا حوالي 24%
من القمح العالمي وحوالي 19 في المئه من
الشعير الى جانب 60% من صادرات العالم من
زيد عباد الشمس وسلعه اخرى كثيره جدا
وكثير من هذه السلع بيخرج من موانئ
الدولتين عبر البحر الاسود وبالتالي شل
الحياه شل الفلاحه التجاريه في البحر
الاسود سوف يؤثر على وصول هذه المنتجات
الى دول العالم المختلفه الخطر الثاني هو
احتمال تعميق ازمه الطاقه مجددا
بحر الاسود بينقل حوالي 3% من نفط العالم
والمنتجات النفطيه روسيا وحدها تصدر يعني
تاريخيا حوالي 750 الف برميل من النفط
الخام يوميا عبر البحر الاسود يعني حوالي
20% من صادرتها من هذا من النفط الخام
طبعا الكميه دي ممكن تكون قلت مؤخرا لانه
الروس حابين يقللوا انتاجهم علشان يعززوا
سعر البرميل لكن الشاهد انه في نسبه مقدره
من النفط الروسي فضلا عن نفط اذربيجان او
غازيها ومصادر مختلفه يعني من الطاقه
البترول والغاز بيمر عبر البحر الاسود
اشتعال البحر الاسود يؤثره على تجاره
البترول والغاز اللي هي عصب الاقتصاد
العالمي وده سوق غير مرن يعني في اسواق
لما
تتاثر منه اثنين او ثلاثه في الميه يقدر
يعوضهم من اسواق اخرى اسواق النفط والغاز
معروف في الاقتصاد بانها اسواق غير مرنه
يعني تحتاج الى فتره طويله جدا علشان تعوض
اي نقص بيصيب احد مصادرها الاساسيه الخطر
الثالث هو ان البحر الاسود اصبح منطقه
احتكاك خطره بين الروس وحلف شمال الاطلسي
رو بتسعى لتعزيز وجودها في البحر بينما
يحرص الحلف في المقابل على تعزيز قواته
هناك للدفاع عن مصالحي وحلفائي وحقه في
حريه الملاحه الامنه واصلا قطع الطريق على
مساعي روسيا ان تجعل من البحر الاسود
بحيره روسيه الامر اللي بيجعل من فرص
الاشتباك بين روسيا
والحلف قائمه وخطيره الخلاصه ان حرب البحر
الاسود ليست الا مرحله اخرى من هذه الحرب
التي يبدو انها سوف تطول كثيرا ومعها يقول
لنا حلقات اخرى باذن الله اشكركم والى